yeah do you not i told and by the way i
totally
i'm not someone who's like ah you know
uh cancel culture is ruining the world
and all this [ __ ] like people are
entitled to get offended by things you
say and that's fine you know sometimes
things offend me and like you know like
a good example is like you know
chappelle
and and there's a lot of comedians uh uh
ricky gervais recently did a set where
they they just have like a lot of jokes
about trans people now a lot of people
think that's funny and um you know and
fine and there's a lot of trans people
or lgbtq plus people who who find it
offensive and like
i don't think it's anyone's right to
tell them well you can't be offended but
you know nobody's nobody's telling them
don't make it either it's just it it's
not that different it's always been i
mean it's just a matter of public
opinion and and and people deciding if
they want to watch you or not except and
i will take this exception do you have
it here so that i can talk about it it
needs like the full
the full context
yes or just play it i'll tell you if
it's good or not
yeah no i'll tell you if it's good or
not well i just think context no i know
we don't have wi-fi here
we got this big beautiful studio no
wi-fi no wi-fi i didn't pay for my uh
monthly he's really cheap
yeah
are you really cheap
it's that jewish dad thing yeah how many
my dad my jewish dad is the cheapest man
i've ever known really not even close we
should pool our money together
at the nra meeting that's today in texas
someone should bomb that building
is it bad advice to say like go outside
ted cruz house and just shoot no no no
this this is the thing this is like a
compilation of stuff this is a
compilation of really defensive stuff
it's not the good one that's a bad one
or you think that's bad oh no it's just
that they cut out the to make it seem
more offensive where they go here's
the 10 second part where i say the nra
and here's the part where i say you know
go outside ted cruz's house and shoot
blanks
okay but but it let's just say
let's take the first statement
the fact that we we you and me both yeah
are putting things out there on the
airway i don't think anyone's going to
then all right i think you should watch
the clip before you okay make a decision
if you think it's like a no i'm just
saying that you don't so you have no i
do take no i take i think i have a lot
of responsibility with what i say i i
take what i say uh very seriously and i
and i think that what people say has an
effect on the world and affects people
so i do take that seriously right like
um i i acknowledge that i just think in
this case
that's not what happened okay i don't
know that we were going to talk about
this and i wasn't talking about this
it's just that when i when you said i'll
be on and then i go to youtube and it
says
it's fine it was just a time book i'll
talk about anything anything anything
is there we're talking about this
specifically and you said oh this
in the context this
specifically you think was taken out of
context and is fine and you don't
necessarily regret saying it but there's
been a lot of like
montages of stuff that people take
offense to yeah is there anything that
you look back on because you've been
doing it for a while that you're like i
wish i didn't say or do that of course a
lot of stuff i said a lot of super
insensitive stuff
that like
i think i there was an edgier time in my
uh career babies i think well sure yeah
and i mean culturally i think people
there was things that we said
that are not acceptable today but
considering all that even aside there's
a lot of things that i've uh said in the
past that i
uh am embarrassed by and you know
what it doesn't take away
no it doesn't go away and the only thing
you can do is basically own it
uh not hide from it acknowledge it i'll
acknowledge it as many times as i need
to and and you know that's that's part
of life and that's part of being a
public figure i'm not i'm embarrassed by
it but i'm not i'm not going to shy away
from anything i've seen you're more
public than i would ever dream to be you
know i saw that i also tuned in to you a
while back you know i don't think you're
doing it with her anymore but there was
that uh what's her name trish that's
what i wanted to bring up you just
announced that it's coming back right
that was a that was a troll ah
you got me i was so excited yeah no well
what i did is i said
ugh yeah it was a troll i'm sorry it was
just an oliver tree podcast oh but it
was a good one it was very good you got
her and i was so excited i'm sorry i
know but you're not in you know are you
on good terms with her no
horrible
[Music]